[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde je me présente je
m'appelle claire
j'ai 24 ans et je suis créatrice de
contenus sur les réseaux sociaux plus
communément appelée influence us
aujourd'hui je suis venu vous parler de
mon expérience que j'ai vécue il ya pas
si longtemps que ça d'être parti tout
seul pendant trois mois en asie du sud
alors pour certains ça va paraître
totalement normal pour d'autres juste
inconscient ou juste inenvisageables
parce que c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude en france de voir des filles
faire ce genre de démarche partir seul
à l'autre bout du monde juste avec un
petit sac à dos sans trop savoir ce qui
va se passer le lendemain
alors évidemment je suis pas la première
à l'avoir fait certainement pas la
dernière mais je voulais juste en venir
au fait que c'est pas commun chez nous
moi je me souviens avant de partir on me
disait toujours mais tu vas vraiment
partir tout seul
t'as pas peur qu'il arrive quelque chose
tu as pas peur d'avoir une galère et de
te retrouver seul
alors pour vous expliquer un petit peu
pourquoi j'ai décidé de faire ce voyage
je vais vous expliquer un peu ce qui
s'est passé avant j'ai fait une école de
commerce et pendant mes études
supérieures
j'ai eu la chance de faire plusieurs
échanges universitaires un premier à
valence en espagne
j'étais trop contente c'était la
première fois que je partais du cocon
familial
j'avais 19 ans et c'était ma première
immersion vers l'inconnu bon je parle
d'immersion mais pour être très honnête
c'était pas vraiment très immersif je
suis resté quasiment qu'avec des
français dans un cadre très scolaire
très encadrée bref je pas vraiment sorti
de ma zone de confort en 4e année j'ai
eu l'occasion de repartir une deuxième
fois en échange
et là je pouvais partir dans le monde
entier j'aurais pu partir aux etats-unis
au canada en australie
tout le monde en rêve un petit peu mais
moi je voulais pas refaire les mêmes
erreurs que la première fois du coup je
voulais un truc vraiment différent je
voulais aller dans un endroit où je
serai pas forcément aller par moi même
et comme j'étais
jour était très intriguée par l'asie du
sud j'ai décidé de partir six mois à
bangkok
quand j'étais à l'université là bas
j'étais en résidence universitaire avec
énormément de français mais surtout avec
des gens du monde entier
c'était vraiment génial je suis resté
avec des allemands des anglais des
espagnols des gens vraiment de partout
dans le monde
et si je dois être honnête avec vous
quand je suis arrivé mon anglais il
était catastrophique
j'avais du mal à comprendre les autres
et j'avais surtout énormément de mal à
me faire comprendre mais j'ai beaucoup
appris grâce à eux et je me suis rendu
compte que si j'osais pas leur parler à
cause de la barrière de la langue
eh ben mon anglais il s'améliorait
jamais parce que je pense que tant qu'on
vit pas en immersion avec des gens qui
parlent pas le français
c'est très compliqué d'apprendre une
nouvelle langue pendant ce voyage je
suis vraiment rester avec des gens de
partout du coup et je me suis rendu
compte à quel point c'était une richesse
exceptionnelle d'échanger avec des gens
du monde entier parce que malgré le fait
que on est tous nos valeurs on est tous
notre culture dans le fond on est tous
un petit peu pareil quand je suis revenu
en france
ça m'a tout de suite manqué je voulais
repartir je voulais re découvrir de
nouveaux des gens et malgré le fait que
je n'ai pas beaucoup voyagé en étant
jeune
c'est cet échange universitaire qui m'a
permis de cultiver mon amour pour
laventure je me suis dit que à la fin de
mes études je repartirai découvrir le
monde alors je sais que c'est un rêve de
que beaucoup partagent mais moi je me
suis dit que j'allais le faire pour de
vrai donc en juillet 2019
j'ai fini mon stage de fin d'études il
faut savoir que à ce moment là j'étais
pas forcément très bien dans ma vie
j'avais accumulé énormément de stress
énormément de situations je me
reconnaissais plus trop dans ma vie de
tous les jours et j'avais besoin de
faire un break
du coup au début j'ai tout de suite
cherché à partir avec quelqu'un qui je
me suis vite rendu compte que si
j'attendais que quelqu'un parte avec moi
mais en fait je partirai jamais parce
qu'il y avait que moi qui pouvais le
faire pour de vrai j'étais jamais partie
seule avant et j'avais peur je pense un
peu comme tout le monde mais je pense
que j'étais surtout pas dans le bon
contexte
au mois de septembre 2019 j'ai pris mes
jambes à mon cou et j'ai pris un avion
pour bangkok une ville que je
connaissais déjà et quand je suis arrivé
à l'auberge
j'étais seul mais pas pour très
longtemps
en fait ce que les gens appréhendent le
plus dans un road-trip solo c'est la
solitude c'est le fait de ne pas réussir
à aborder les autres le fait de d'avoir
une galère et d'être seul pour la
résoudre et de pas pouvoir partager tous
ces moments précieux qu'on est en train
de vivre avec des gens qu'on connaît
mais moi très honnêtement pour être
parti trois mois en solitaire je peux
vous dire qu'on n'est jamais vraiment
seul
et quand on l'est c'est qu'on l'a décidé
en fait les gens ont peur de ne pas
réussir à aborder des personnes qui ne
connaissent pas parce qu'ils s'imaginent
la situation comme si elle se passait
chez nous comme si moi demain si un bar
était ouvert j'allais voir un groupe de
personnes et que j'allais leur demander
est-ce que je peux m'asseoir avec vous
donc c'est pas forcément sûr qu'ils me
disent non mais la situation serait un
petit peu cocasse parce que dans notre
mentalité française dans notre culture
quand quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas viens
nous voir il ya toujours une forme de
méfiance est en fait faut savoir que
pendant un road trip et plus
particulièrement en asie parce que c'est
là que je suis parti ces codes ils sont
complètement cassé il ya plus de je ne
connais pas donc je ne te parle pas
parce que dans le fond on est tous là
pour la même chose on a tous soif de
découverte du monde mais aussi de
découverte vers les autres on partage
tous la même valeur de vouloir apprendre
de l'autre et ce qui est drôle c'est que
vous allez rencontrer des gens avec qui
ça colle tout de suite d'autres
personnes vous avez l'impression qu'ils
sont sur une autre planète des gens
hyper gentil hyperfestive des timides
des rigolos il y en a vraiment pour tous
les goûts mois pour être très honnête
avec vous j'ai jamais sentie autant de
chaleur et d'hospitalité que pendant ce
voyage
en fait c'est la solidarité qui prône
toujours demain vous avez un accident
parlant de scooter vous allez rentrer à
l'auberge
il y aura toujours quelqu'un qui sera là
pour vous aider pour vous demander si
vous avez besoin d'aller à l'hôpital
si vous avez besoin d'un pansement si
vous avez besoin d'un médicament demain
vous perdez quelque chose pareille
les gens seront là pour essayer de
trouver une solution moi par exemple
pendant mon voyage j'ai cassé mon
téléphone
j'ai cassé mon téléphone à callao c'est
un tout petit village au fin fond du
myanmar
juste avant de partir quatre jours en
trek dans une campagne complètement
perdu donc en soit je savais que
j'allais pas avoir de réseau et qu'il
n'avait pas besoin de mon téléphone
il faut savoir que dans ce genre de
voyage notre téléphone c'est la seule
chose qui nous rattache à notre
quotidien c'est la seule chose qui
permet de communiquer avec sa famille
avec ses amis et pouvoir surtout donné
garder ce contact en fait et moi ce qui
me stressait le plus c'est de rompre ce
lien qui était si précieux pour moi pour
être juste stabilisée épanouie dans mon
voyage
du coup la première chose auquel on a
pensé c'était trouver un endroit où je
pouvais réparer la vitre de mon
téléphone
mais évidemment on était dans un tout
petit village donc autant vous dire que
c'était pas possible
deuxième option trouver un nouveau
téléphone est pareil il était 20h je
partais 6 heures le lendemain matin je
savais je me suis vite mis dans la tête
que ce serait pas possible non plus
alors du coup je suis rentré à l'auberge
un petit peu dépité et surtout un petit
peu triste et en arrivant dans mon
dortoir
j'ai rencontré un allemand quelqu'un que
j'avais jamais vu auparavant qui a vu
que j'allais pas forcément très bien et
qui m'a simplement proposé de me prêter
son téléphone de rechange
on n'allait pas faire le même trac on
n'allait pas partir exactement au même
endroit se suivre à la trace
mais simplement il a vu que j'étais pas
bien et il m'a dit on va se retrouver
dans une ville prochainement on se donne
un endroit de rendez vous dans une
auberge où finira bien par se retrouver
et tu me rendre à mon téléphone quand on
a réparé le tien waouh
quelle confiance j'étais surprise mais
surtout très émerveillés par autant de
gentillesse et générosité de la part de
quelqu'un que je ne connaissais pas du
tout en fait faut savoir que dans ce
genre de contexte les émotions elles
sont découplées c'est pas tellement le
téléphone qui était important c'est le
geste qu'il a fait envers moi parce qu'à
ce moment là on fait exactement aux
autres ce qu'on aimerait qu'on nous
fasse à nous même et rien d'en parler
j'ai beaucoup d'émotion parce que je me
demande pourquoi ça se passe pas
exactement pareil chez nous je vous ai
parlé beaucoup de la découverte de
l'autre mais j'aimerais aussi vous
parler de la découverte de moi même le
vrai moi celui que j'ai au plus profond
de moi même quand j'étais en voyage là
bas j'avais pas besoin d'être quelqu'un
que je n'étais pas pour la simple et
bonne raison que je passais ma vie avec
des gens
j'avais très peu de chances de recroiser
dans le futur donc je n'avais pas besoin
de réagir de telle ou de telle façon et
ça c'est une vraie liberté j'avais
personne pour me juger personne pour me
faire des reproches
juste des ans kim accepté comme j'étais
vraiment et ça c'est une belle leçon
lits auxquels je pense souvent au
quotidien pour rester dans ce sentiment
de liberté
je voulais vous parler de mon sentiment
préféré au monde que j'ai ressenti que
là bas et que j'espère revivre très
prochainement de nouveaux c'est un
sentiment de liberté à l'état pur quand
on est dans ce genre de voyage
on veut profiter de chaque instant parce
qu'on sait qu'on est en train de vivre
quelque chose de fou du coup on s'arrête
jamais on fait des visites on rencontre
du monde
on s'arrête pas et moi mon seul moment
de recueillement
c'était quand j'étais dans le bus pour
changer de ville c'était le moment où
j'arrivais à prendre un petit peu de
recul sur la situation et à me rendre
compte à quel point j'avais de la chance
et que c'était merveilleux ce que
j'étais en train de vivre
donc maintenant imaginez vous dans un
bus de nuit avec de la musique dans les
oreilles
vous allez vers un endroit que vous ne
connaissez pas ou personnes vous attend
en fait vous faites ce que vous voulez
moi si j'ai envie de descendre du bus à
la prochaine station service est pas
allé jusqu'à ma destination finale je
peux le faire s'il n'y a rien qui m'en
empêche
je fais vraiment ce que je veux avec qui
je veux et quand je veux et c'est pas
une métaphore c'est vraiment la réalité
mon seul but c'est de m'écouter moi et
mes envies
alors évidemment je vais pas non plus
vous dire que pendant tout le voyage ça
a été tout rose tous les jours que
j'étais au top de mon épanouissement 24
heures sur 24
ce serait vous mentir mais ça fait
partie des leçons personnel que j'ai
appris sur moi-même parce qu'il ya des
choses tant qu'on les a pas vécues
on n'arrive pas à se rendre compte moi
j'avais beau être à l'autre bout du
monde
des milliers de possibilités qui
s'offraient à moi mon quotidien me
manquait énormément
ma famille me manque et mes amis me
manquaient mon appartement de 20 m² à
paris me manquer ma vie normale quoi et
en fait c'est parce que j'ai réussi à
prendre du recul et que j'ai découvert
de nouvelles choses que aujourd'hui ma
vie de tous les jours est aussi
appréciable
donc je vous parle de ça comme d'une
expérience de vie mais vous comprendrez
jamais vraiment ce que j'ai ressenti
tant que vous l'aurez pas vécu vous même
il faut arriver à braver ses limites à
casser les barrières et à aller au-delà
de ce qu'on peut faire
si on en a vraiment envie alors
évidemment je sais que tout le monde
n'est pas capable d'aller à l'autre bout
du monde seul mais déjà si vous l'osez
partir de chez vous n'aime pas très loin
pour vous retrouver un petit peu je suis
sûr et je suis quasiment persuadée que
vous en découvrirez déjà beaucoup sur
vous même merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]